[Musique]
après la promulgation samedi la loi
relative à l'accélération de la
production des énergies renouvelables
voici venu le temps de vous prononcer
sur le deuxième pilier de la stratégie
de transition énergétique conduite par
le gouvernement la relance de notre
filière nucléaire ces deux textes ont un
point commun celui de répondre à une
seule et même ambition faire de la
France le premier grand pays industriel
à sortir de sa dépendance aux énergies
fossiles c'est le seul combat qui vaille
tant pour des raisons climatiques et de
concorde social que pour des raisons
d'indépendance économiques et donc
politique
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro des grands débats consacré à la
relance du nucléaire l'objectif de ce
projet de loi si nouveau réacteurs
européen avec une première mise en
service en 2035 concrètement il s'agit
de trouver des nouveaux sites
d'installation et de prolonger la durée
de vie des réacteurs existants la
majorité présidentielle les républicains
et le rassemblement national sont
favorables à cette relance du nucléaire
mais la nupes est divisée la France
insoumise et les écologistes sont contre
les communistes sont plutôt pour et les
socialistes sont indécis
lorsqu'on parle d'énergie la culture
scientifique doit être entendue et c'est
bien sur la science que ça puis la
stratégie énergétique du président de la
République énoncé à Belfort elle repose
sur trois indissociables piliers que
nous mettons en œuvre avec la première
ministre et la majorité d'une part la
réduction de la consommation d'énergie
qui passe par la sobriété l'efficacité
énergétique si nous voulons atteindre la
neutralité carbone les experts de RTE
nous le disent nous devrons réduire de
40% notre consommation d'énergie à
horizon 2050 le plan de sobriété que
j'ai présenté en octobre dernier et la
première brique de cette trajectoire de
long terme grâce à la mobilisation des
grandes entreprises des grandes
collectivités des grandes
administrations et plus largement des
Françaises et des Français ce plan a
permis à notre pays de réduire de 10% sa
consommation de gaz et d'électricité
combiner cet hiver c'est à dire
l'équivalent de la production de cette
réacteurs nous avons ainsi su faire en
trois mois ce que d'autres pays en dépit
de certaines lois n'a pas su faire en 30
ans d'autre part notre stratégie
énergétique repose sur l'augmentation
massive et durable de notre production
d'énergie décarbonée je l'ai dit nous
n'avons pas le luxe du dogmatisme nous
devons accélérer la production de toutes
les énergies décarbonées disponibles dès
lors qu'elles sont compatibles avec
notre indépendance énergétique et
qu'elle contribue à fournir à nos
concitoyens une énergie abondante et
abordable notre stratégie implique donc
de développer massivement les énergies
renouvelables et de relancer l'énergie
nucléaire et sur ce point assumons de le
dire sans dix tour oui notre pays a un
lien historique avec la technologie
nucléaire oui ce lien est le fruit d'une
volonté politique forte et ambitieuse
celle du général de Gaulle et de ses
successeurs c'est bien dans cet héritage
politique que s'inscrit le programme de
relance porté par le Président de la
République des partenaires européens
affichent désormais stratégie similaire
à la nôtre la Suède les Pays-Bas la
Belgique la République tchèque ou encore
la Roumanie pour ne citer que cela on
manifesté leur souhait de se doter de
nouvelles capacités de production
nucléaire ou de prolonger l'utilisation
de leur capacités nucléaires existantes
j'ai d'ailleurs lancé avec 11 de mes
homologues européens une alliance
européenne du nucléaire pour renforcer
nos coopérations et conforter notre
autonomie stratégique dans ce domaine
une alliance qui vise à défendre la
contribution du nucléaire à nos
objectifs climatiques il y a la sécurité
énergétique de notre continent c'est
absolument stratégique car l'avenir du
nucléaire se joue aussi au niveau
européen
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Madame Maud Brejon
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
économiques avec ce texte nous assumons
pleinement notre ambition pour cette
filière là où d'autres voudraient en
sortir à tout prix et je commencerai par
là
nous supprimons enfin le plafond qui
limite la part du nucléaire à 50% dans
le mix électrique et la limite de
capacité installées deux dispositions
introduites sous le quinquennat de
François Hollande pour affaiblir la
filière sur la base de considération
idéologique et sur fond d'accord
politiqueien avec les verres pourtant le
nucléaire est une part de notre histoire
nationale qu'aucun président de la 5e
République de droite comme de gauche
n'avait alors remis en cause chacun et
c'est tout à leur honneur avait préservé
ce fleuron industriel et le consensus
national qu'il l'entourait pour en
revenir au cœur technique du projet de
loi la première partie du texte crée des
dispositions temporaires pour accélérer
le renouvellement de notre parc
historique si certains ont délais sont
évidemment justifiés tels que
l'instruction l'autorisation de création
sur laquelle nous ne revenons pas
d'autres peuvent être résorbées
cette construction est doublement
encadrée à l'article premier
d'une part dans l'espace ces
dispositions ne valant que pour les
réacteurs installés à proximité
d'installation existante et d'autre part
dans le temps puisque ces mesures ne
seront applicables que pour une durée
limitée de 20 ans
durée pour laquelle nous nous sommes
accordés avec le Sénat à titre d'exemple
l'article de accélère la processus la
procédure de mise en compatibilité de
documents d'urbanisme avec les projets
de construction tout en associant les
collectivités l'article 3 intègre le
contrôle de la conformité aux règles
d'urbanisme des nouveaux réacteurs à
l'autorisation environnementale
permettant ainsi de supprimer l'étape
des autorisations d'urbanisme au profit
d'un contrôle global et rigoureux par
l'autorité environnementale
l'article 4 est d'une est une des
dispositions les plus importantes du
texte et permet de débuter les travaux
hors ilonucléaire dès la délivrance de
l'autorisation environnementale si une
anticipation qui ne concerne pas le
coeur de l'installation et les systèmes
de sûreté mais qui permettra aux mètres
d'ouvrages de prendre de l'avance sur
certaines étapes du chemin critique du
planning et donc de limiter les risques
de retard en cascade
la seconde partie du projet de loi porte
quant à elle sur des installations
nucléaires existantes et intègre en fait
ni plus ni moins que des mesures de bon
sens je pense notamment à l'article 10
qui supprime l'arrêt la mise à l'arrêt
automatique d'une installation nucléaire
de base lorsqu'elle n'a pas fonctionné
depuis plus de 2 ans il n'y a pas de
sens est-ce que l'arrêt soit automatique
alors même que la volonté de redémarrer
par l'exploitant et bien là et que
simplement il peut y avoir des incidents
qui nécessitent d'allonger les durées
d'arrêt on a des exemples à budget comme
un Paluel ce n'est pas au gouvernement
quel qu'il soit de juger de la sûreté
d'une installation et de sa capacité à
produire en fonctionnement normal dans
un contexte mondial où les besoins
d'électricité sont croissants nous
disposons dorénavons de moins de 30 ans
pour atteindre l'objectif de neutralité
carbone que nous nous sommes fixés à cet
égard le groupe socialiste est apparenté
n'est pas principalement anti-nucléaires
nous assumons même la nécessité de cette
énergie décarbonée et pilotable une
énergie de transition à même d'éviter
que les dérèglement climatique ne soient
irréversible pour autant nous ne pouvons
pas raisonnablement à prouver la relance
que vous proposez et ce pour plusieurs
raisons premièrement parce que votre
projet va irrémédiablement se heurter à
la complexité du réel la France n'a pas
mené de programme de construction de
plusieurs réacteurs quasi simultanément
depuis de plus de 20 ans ce constat est
synonyme d'un véritable manque de
compétences industrielle nos flamants
ville 3 et certainement le meilleur
exemple d'une dégradation notable de
l'outil de production et enfin d'un
délitement du tissu des sous-traitants
dont nous payons collectivement le prix
aujourd'hui tout cela l'Autorité de
Sûreté Nucléaire on a parfaitement
conscience raison pour laquelle elle
appelle un appelant Marshall qui
pourrait s'avérer être une chimère
l'exploitant EDF ne dit pas autre chose
la pyramide des âges entraînera le
départ à la retraite de 70 000 des 220
000 travailleurs de la filière dans les
années à venir dans le même temps la
relance Souha nécessitera environ 300
000 personnes pour la rendre effective
il va donc falloir trouver et former 150
000 ingénieurs techniciens ouvriers au
cours des 10 prochaines années dans des
secteurs parfois en très forte tension à
l'heure où les factures énergétiques des
Français s'envolent nous veillerons
légitimement tout au long de l'examen de
ce texte à ce que leurs intérêts soient
préservés dès lors nous adopterons notre
position sur ce texte à l'évolution des
débats et aux sorts qui sera réservé à
nos propositions d'amendements au cours
des prochains jours notre pays la France
veut effectuer effectivement être la
première grande nation à sortir des
énergies fossiles sa stratégie repose en
premier lieu sur un important et fort de
sobriété énergétique le plan mis en
oeuvre depuis cet automne visant à
réduire de 10% notre consommation
énergétique en deux ans et de 40% en
2050 en est la preuve mais au-delà de
cet effort de sobriété il nous faut
surtout dès à présent remplacer les
énergies fossiles qui constituent les
deux tiers de l'énergie consommée par
notre pays par le biais d'énergie bas
carbone le nucléaire répond à ce défi de
décarbonation et représente une énergie
garant de notre souveraineté le présent
projet de loi s'inscrit dans cette
démarche et prévoit des mesures
indispensables pour réunir les
conditions juridiques et financières et
d'organisation nécessaires à la relance
d'une politique ambitieuse en matière de
nucléaire civile en programmant 6
nouveaux eperes 2 et l'étude de la
construction de 8 paires 2 additionnels
le groupe horizon apparenté tient à
saluer l'équilibre de ce texte présenté
par le gouvernement et les objectifs et
avancer qu'il comportent pour lequel
notre groupe a pris toute sa part en
complément la loi sur les énergies
renouvelables que nous avons adopté il y
a quelques semaines ce texte nous
permettra de mobiliser l'ensemble des
différences sources d'énergie bas
carbone pour atteindre l'objectif de
neutralité carbone que nous sommes
collectivement fixés et d'assurer la
souveraineté énergétique de la France je
vous remercie je suis une femme je ne
suis pas ingénieur du nucléaire je suis
une citoyenne qui s'interroge
légitimement sur un sujet sciemment
confisqué par des experts
avec toujours des mots rassurants ne
vous inquiétez pas vous ne connaissez
pas le sujet mais tout est sous contrôle
vraiment le nuage de Tchernobyl s'est
arrêté à nos frontières vraiment si
Flamanville est un fiasco industriel et
financier c'est la faute des antinuaires
vraiment si la moitié de nos réacteurs
étaient à l'arrêt cet été et qu'on a dû
recourir au charbon c'est là encore la
faute des antiprogressistes
l'accumule l'accumulation des déchets
radioactifs extrêmement dangereux pour
des milliers d'années ne pose pas de
problème le nucléaire c'est
l'indépendance énergétique de la France
vraiment ne sommes-nous pas mains et
point liés à la Russie de Vladimir
Poutine
les débats du nucléaire sont uniquement
la faute des écologistes vraiment les
mêmes mots depuis des décennies
minimisant les risques et brimant celles
et ceux qui posent des questions
légitimes car oui dans le pays le plus
nucléarisé au monde on est en droit de
s'interroger en plus de 50 ans
l'industrie nucléaire n'a résolu aucun
des problèmes qu'elle était censé
résoudre dans ce contexte est-ce
raisonnable de décaler l'âge de départ à
la retraite de nos vieux réacteurs alors
qu'il souffre déjà de leur
vieillissement j'en veux pour preuve la
découverte nouvelle fissure d'une
ampleur inégalée sur les sites de Pandi
et quatre noms les défaillances graves
s'enchaînent et qui auraient pu prédire
Marcel Boiteux PDG d'EDF jusqu'en 1979
il expliquait que la longévité des
réacteurs a été calculée pour 12000
cycles thermiques soit un peu plus de 30
ans la corrosion sous contrainte n'est
donc pas un mauvais sort mais bien une
suite logique du vieillissement des
centrales et nous voudrions parier sur
leur prolongation sans attendre la
validation de la SN vous choisissez de
saboter notre objectif de réduction du
nucléaire pour mieux le relancer que
l'on soit pour ou contre l'énergie
nucléaire notre intérêt le même nous
devons nous préserver le plus possible
d'un accident pourtant en deux
amendements vous actez à la hussardes le
démantèlement de l'IRSN ce choix de
ruiner dans la précipitation un système
dual robuste construit sur des décennies
et particulièrement irresponsable et
dangereux l'énergie est un bien commun
un bien de première nécessité nous en
avons besoin pour vivre nous déplacer
pour faire fonctionner le pays
dans cet esprit les questions liées à
son approvisionnement à son cou pour les
usagers dont les 8 millions de précaires
énergétiques mais aussi pour notre
économie réelle sont des questions
primordiales essentielles des questions
de souveraineté même dans le même temps
personne ne peut ignorer l'urgence
climatique qui bouscule non seulement
les équilibres vitaux de la planète mais
aussi nos modes de vie la lutte contre
le réchauffement climatique la réduction
des gaz à effet de serre
l'électrification des usages pour sortir
des énergies fossiles sont d'une urgence
telle
en politique les Français ont tout vu
ils tireront d'eux-mêmes les
conséquences pour leur futur choix
électoraux nous choisissons d'aller de
l'avant et de soutenir toutes les
mesures qui évitent le pire animé comme
toujours par le seul intérêt national la
fin du mensonge d'état des 50% de
production électrique nucléaire dans
notre mix électrique est un premier pas
mais le choix de lancer seulement 6 plus
huit réacteurs d'ici 2050 ne permet ni
de produire assez d'électricité ni de
rebâtir une filière industrielle forte
et durable chers collègues vous avez été
la majorité qui a mis notre filière
nucléaire dans la pire impasse
l'occasion historique vous est donnée
d'en sortir la France ne peut se
permettre de la gâcher s'il vous plaît
ne la gâchez pas de Gaulle est mort
c'était au 20e siècle et comme le
nucléaire je doute qu'il puisse incarner
notre avenir c'est pourtant ainsi que ce
rêve le président Macron prêt à tous les
passages en force pour assouvir ses
caprices comme un atteste ce nouveau
projet de loi un passage en force qui
s'inscrit dans un calendrier abscons en
janvier le Parlement adopté une loi sur
les énergies renouvelables qui les
freinent plus qu'il ne les encourage par
ce texte vous prévoyez la construction
de 14 réacteurs une relance du nucléaire
qui passerait par des technologies de
type EPR 2 dont l'année dont
l'ingénierie n'est toujours pas abouti
ou SMS qui sont aujourd'hui à l'état de
prototype et qui s'accompagnerait de la
prolongation décentrales existantes de
10 20 ou 30 ans ce texte impose d'abord
un coup de force réglementaire avec un
seul objectif permettre aux présidents
de couper le ruban du chantier d'une
centrale avant la fin de son mandat
recentralisation des procédures
d'urbanisme contournement des procédures
environnementales et de participation du
public le Conseil d'État a pourtant
estimé que le gain de temps espéré par
ces mesures dérogatoires ne peut être
évaluée avec certitude pire au détour
d'un amendement gouvernemental ce texte
impose un passage en force sur la sûreté
nucléaire avec le projet de
démantèlement de l'URSS sans la moindre
étude d'impact enfin l'Assemblée
nationale va se prononcer sur un texte
de relance du nucléaire enfin la France
va reprendre le fil de cette histoire
écrite par le général de Gold et la
libération pour doter le pays des moyens
de son indépendance énergétique en 2012
le président François Hollande a
sacrifié ce consensus en décidant de
réduire la part du nucléaire à 50% de
notre production d'électricité pourquoi
50 % il ne s'agit sans doute pas
d'autres choses que d'une poire
électorale coupée en deux sur un coin de
table avec les verres mais c'est bien
sous la présidence d'Emmanuel Macron que
les décisions les plus fatales à la
filière nucléaire ont été prises
décisions de fermer 14 réacteurs en
novembre 2018 alors que Jean-Martin
folle savait remis à Nicolas hulnot
Hulot et à Bruno Le Maire un rapport 3
mois plus tôt seulement invitant le
gouvernement à saisir l'urgence de
construire 6 nouveaux EPR abandon du
projet Astrid le réacteur de la
quatrième génération vente de la branche
énergie d'Alstom à l'Américain général
électrique fermeture définitive de
Fessenheim en juin 2020 quel étrange
nous renonçons au nucléaires nous
démobilisons toute la filière et puis un
beau jour de février 2022 à deux mois
d'élection présidentielle le président
Macron réalise un des plus
spectaculaires tête à queue de notre
histoire politique il n'est plus
question de fermer 14 réacteurs mais
dans construire 14 quel cirque si le
groupe si notre groupe est évidemment
favorable à ce revirement de l'histoire
au nom de la souveraineté énergétique de
la France au nom de la compétitivité de
notre économie mais aussi au nom du
climat vous comprendrez madame la
ministre que nous sommes peu enclins à
faire une confiance aveugle à ceux qui
se sont le plus trompés au regard de
l'actualité depuis un an avec la guerre
en Ukraine et toutes les conséquences
qu'elle entraîne dans l'ordre mondial et
dans la vie quotidienne des Français
notre responsabilité la plus urgente et
de reprendre en main notre souveraineté
elle nous commande d'assurer à long
terme notre souveraineté énergétique
garante de nos libertés
lors de l'accord de Paris l'engagement a
été pris de limiter l'augmentation de la
température moyenne de la planète en
dessous de 2 degrés par rapport au
niveau préindustriel tel doit être
l'objectif qui nous réunit au-delà de
notre bord politique concrètement cet
engagement se traduit par une maîtrise
de notre empreinte carbone à environ 2
tonnes de CO2 par an par français d'ici
2050 nous y sommes encore loin notre
empreinte carbone est actuellement de
8,9 tonnes par an ainsi pour arriver à
tenir cet objectif les efforts à
entreprendre sont conséquent la
politique des petits gestes n'est pas
suffisante et nous avons besoin d'une
politique volontariste en la matière
afin de respecter nos objectifs
climatiques au niveau du groupe
démocrate nous partageons la double
exigence de la nécessaire sobriété et de
la décarbonation de nos modes de vie la
sobriété est la mère des priorités mais
ce ne doit toutefois pas être une
sobriété sans technologie ou sans
innovation ni une sobriété qui menace
nos libertés ind visuel d'autre part une
part incompressible de nos activités
nécessitent une consommation d'énergie
notre deuxième priorité est donc de la
décarboner pour ce faire la fin de notre
dépendance aux énergies fossiles et
l'électrification de nos usages sont
indispensables il en va également de
notre souveraineté économique afin de
lancer le chantier industriel de ce
siècle il est nécessaire d'avoir un cap
une vision et une détermination claire
le groupe démocratie est engagé et notre
main ne tremblera pas en votant en
faveur de ce texte
avec l'article premier a le gouvernement
souhaite supprimer la réduction à 50% de
la part du nucléaire dans la production
d'électricité à l'horizon 2035 une
décision prise à l'époque par François
Hollande
[Musique]
l'énergie nucléaire garantit la
souveraineté énergétique de la France et
offre évidemment une électricité
décarbonée compétitive pilotable et sûr
par idéologie et clientélisme électorale
la gauche a arbitrairement et contre
toute rationalité scientifique imposer
la réduction à 50 % de la part du
nucléaire dans le mix électrique
français il aura fallu malheureusement
attendre que la France risque de se
retrouver dans le noir attendre que les
particuliers les entreprises soient
contraint à la sobriété attendre de
devoir relancer une centrale à charbon
face aux risques de pénurie pour que le
gouvernement décide enfin de supprimer
le plafond absurde des 50% de nucléaires
dans la production électrique française
que de temps de perdus bien évidemment
les députés du rassemblement national
voteront pour cet article qui permet
enfin de relancer le nucléaire dans
notre pays dans cet article 1er a il est
proposé tout simplement de supprimer la
part du du nucléaire dans le mix
énergétique qui était plafonné à 50%
ainsi que le plafond de cap s'est
installé à 63 gigawatts en fait vous
êtes en train d'atomiser la
programmation plus réelle de l'énergie
RTE
suggère que nous réduisions notre
consommation d'énergie finale de 40%, le
nucléaire représente 20 % de notre
consommation d'énergie finale
c'est-à-dire que si nous remplissions
seulement la moitié du chemin à
parcourir en fait nous pourrions nous
passer du nucléaire un grand débat qui
pourrait parler de l'efficacité mais
pour cela il faut mettre des moyens et
pour l'instant vous le refusez et qui se
qui serait suivi d'un grand débat sur
les technologies ensuite nécessaire pour
atteindre les objectifs de de production
d'énergie qu'il faudrait réaliser en
intégrant tous les scénarios comme
avaient tenté de le faire la CNDP dans
le débat qu'elle a tenté de mener et pas
seulement un seul des scénarios de RTE
le dernier que vous privilégiez avec la
relance du nucléaire mais en fait avec
ce que vous nous avez dit madame la
ministre en commission ni planchait ni
plafond vous êtes pour la croissance
sans limite et finalement je crois que
vous vivez dans un monde sans fin cet
article première
issu d'un amendement sénatorial vise
notamment à supprimer l'objectif de 50%
d'unique de nucléaire dans le dans le
mix énergétique à l'horizon 2035 dans un
contexte où l'urgence climatique
s'impose de plus en plus à notre société
le nucléaire est le meilleur allié des
énergies renouvelables pour aller vers
une société décarbonée avec un mix
énergétique bas carbone et robuste pour
répondre aux objectifs de neutralité
carbone à horizon 2050 les décisions
prises depuis 10 ans sur les centrales
nucléaires par les gouvernements des
présidents Hollande et Macron menace
l'héritage du général de Gaulle qui
voulait garantir aux Français la
souveraineté énergétique nos concitoyens
et nos entreprises je pense notamment au
boulanger au PME de la forge fonderie
aux artisans qui consomment beaucoup
d'énergie fait au prix fort ces
mauvaises décisions depuis quelques mois
si le nucléaire n'avait pas été abordé
depuis 10 ans s'aborder pardon la guerre
nukraine ne menaçait pas dépend entier
de notre économie et de pouvoir d'achat
de nos concitoyens le temps perdu ne
pourra pas être attrapé mais
effectivement nous saluons votre prise
de conscience même si elle est bien
tardive il est urgent de se débarrasser
de notre dépendance au pétrole je crois
que tout le monde est d'accord là dessus
il est urgent de nous débarrasser
[Musique]
de notre dépendance aux énergies
fossiles j'ai rappelé que d'ailleurs
faute d'une stratégie nous avions été
contraint de réouvrir des centrales
thermiques après les avoir fermé
il est urgent d'électrifier les usages
pour faire tout cela et notamment le
virage du thermique vers les véhicules
électriques va participer de cela avec
des fois des inquiétudes que j'ai sur
les conséquences sociales mais il est
impérieux donc si on veut faire tout ça
et pour avoir une énergie décarbonée
d'avoir une énergie pilotable et c'est
la raison pour laquelle parce que parce
qu'on aura tous besoin du jus en même
temps quand on rentre du boulot le
square quand on part le matin et puis en
hiver un peu plus que on était quoi
qu'on était quand les clims fonctionnent
il y a aussi besoin d'énergie ce qui est
pas bien on a besoin d'économiser de
l'énergie il y a besoin de plans
thermiques il y a besoin de plan de
transport j'ai pas de sujet là dessus
mais même en faisant tout ça on a donc
besoin dans le mixte énergétique de la
relance du nucléaire parce que je
rappelle quand même en ce début de
mandat qu'on a frôlé en hiver avec des
mesures avec des
des risques de délestage faute d'être en
situation d'assurer une production
correspondant aux besoins donc je veux
dire tout cela parce que c'est ça qui
habite le groupe communiste dans la
construction d'un mix énergétique et
équilibré intelligent consenti public à
bascourt parce que sinon on ne tiendra
pas y compris cette urgence qu'il y a
assuré une sécurité d'approvisionnement
de Ce bien de première nécessité je
voudrais profiter aussi de revenir sur
qui a été
sur la diminution à 50%
notre
mix strict
t cet accord je vous le recontextualise
nous sommes en 2012 en 2011 il y a la
catastrophe de Fukushima l'opinion
publique et un certain nombre de
personnes assis ici dans cette hémicycle
qui prône la relance du nucléaire en
2011 n'avait pas ces mots-là pourquoi
parce que nous nous sommes réalisés en
France aussi que il y avait des dangers
inhérents à l'énergie nucléaire qui
avait des questions à se poser nous
étions extrêmement dépendants d'une
seule énergie et que donc oui il fallait
diversifier notre mix
et donc c'est la raison pour laquelle
cet accord était fondé sur pas seulement
un état un accord électoraliste mais
aussi l'opinion à ce moment-là qui avait
ouvert les yeux sur les faits les
dangers du nucléaire hier justement nous
étions rassemblés place de la République
pour nous souvenir de la catastrophe de
Fukushima malgré le déni qui gangrène
nos dirigeants nous continuons de nous
souvenir quand on veut parler de
Fukushima on nous répond mais de quoi
parlez-vous Fukushima c'est zéro mort
zéro cancer est-ce de la bêtise s du
cynisme et quand placoplatre extrait du
gypse sans se soucier des déchets
radioactifs qui pullulent dans les sols
du fort de vos jours est-ce de la bêtise
est-ce du cynisme quel désastre vous
faudra-t-il pour comprendre chers
collègues pour comprendre que la
suppression de l'objectif de réduction
de la part du nucléaire est un non-sens
si nous voulons un avenir nous devons
programmer notre sortie du nucléaire
cette énergie du passé
et si vous vous y opposez chers
collègues je ne doute pas que vous serez
volontaire pour accueillir le surplus
des déchets nucléaires dans votre jardin
en tant que ministre en charge de la
transition énergétique j'étais très
heureuse d'avoir contribué au discours
de Belfort qui a enfin donné une vraie
direction énergétique à notre pays mais
aussi en tant que parlementaire quelques
années plus tôt j'étais très heureuse
que nous ayons enfin acté que ce soit
les parlementaires qui décident d'une
loi de programmation énergétique qui
puisse conforter et qui puisse aller
dans la lignée de ce que le président de
la République a annoncé et donc sur la
forme et c'est pourquoi j'ai déposé cet
amendement je pense qu'il faut faire les
choses de manière cohérente on a une loi
de programmation énergétique qui est
prévue dans quelques mois il va falloir
y travailler il y a un débat public qui
a été lancé justement pour éclairer le
débat parlementaire je pense que cette
loi sera très importante donc voilà
pourquoi sur la forme je veux supprimer
cet article premier a qui il me semble
n'a pas lieu d'être dans cette loi qui
est supposée être une loi technique pour
aider à accélérer dans la lignée du
discours de Belfort deuxième point sur
le fond sur le fond quel message
envoie-t-on quand on quand on enlève les
50% nucléaires en disant qu'on peut
aller au-dessus quand on dit qu'on peut
aller au-dessus de 63,2 Go de puissance
installée de nucléaire en critiquant
ceux qui ont fait ça sur un coin de
table en 2015 alors que les scénarios de
RTE qui sont un peu notre base sur
laquelle on travaille les scénarios le
plus nucléarisé celui qui va le plus
loin propose propose 50% de nucléaires
et pas plus et propose un plafond de pas
un plafond mais une production installée
de 51 gigawatts et donc bien loin des
63,2 gigawatts donc pourquoi touche-t-on
même sur le fond à ces chiffres qui de
toute façon ne serait même pas atteint
dans le scénario le plus extrême de RTE
qui a été travaillé pendant deux ans
avec des milliers d'int ervenants je ne
comprends pas donc voilà pourquoi je
demande à supprimer cet article on
enlève la limite du nucléaire on en met
ni sur les énergies renouvelables ni sur
l'hydraulique ni sur le nucléaire quel
sens il y aurait alors qu'on a 60% en
énergie consommée qui vient du fossile
en France 80% dans le monde à se mettre
des limites sur le développement des
objectifs des énergies des carbonées
vous vous trompez de combat vous trompez
d'ennemis et enfin sur cette question
plus globalement des pourcentages
50%
40% peu importe c'est des limites qui
sont idéologiques il faut réfléchir la
question de la production électrique en
terawater plus en pourcentage mettre ce
qu'on est capable de faire les besoins
en face des moyens mais sortir de cette
logique politique dogmatique donc
défavorable vous en arrivons au vote de
l'article 1er je vous rappelle mes chers
collègues qu'il y a un scrutin public
je vous prie de bien vouloir regagner
vos places
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
votant 137 exprimer 133 majorités 67
pour 97 contre 36 l'Assemblée nationale
a adopté
l'article 11 bis sur la réforme de la
Sûreté Nucléaire et vivant contester à
gauche son but fusionner l'IRSN et l'ASN
les deux organismes de contrôle et de
sécurité du nucléaire en France la
gauche demande la suppression de cet
article avec l'appui de quelques voies
de la majorité dont celle de l'ancienne
ministre de la transition écologique
Barbara pompier
[Musique]
on ne réforme pas la sûreté nucléaire à
la légère à la va-vite et à la hussarde
c'est prendre un risque énorme c'est un
luxe que la France ne peut pas se
permettre l'article 11 bis est un
cavalier législatif nous entrons là dans
un débat qui n'est pas un débat de
politique énergétique qui est un débat
de sûreté et que l'on soit pour le
nucléaire pour le nouveau nucléaire pour
la prolongation des centrales nucléaires
ou pour la sortie du nucléaire les
installations nucléaires existantes
doivent fonctionner dans des conditions
de sûreté absolue le démantèlement de
l'IRSN
est un schéma qui n'a fait l'objet
d'aucune étude d'impact qui a été
repoussée par la Cour des comptes qui
est une hypothèse qui a été écartée par
plusieurs ministres en charge de la
sûreté nucléaire et de l'énergie dont je
fais partie qui est une hypothèse qui
est repoussée par trois anciens
présidents de l'Office Parlementaire des
choix techniques et scientifiques de
sensibilité politique différente cette
proposition est dangereuse parce que la
sûreté nucléaire en France repose sur
cinq principes la responsabilité de
l'exploitant l'indépendance de
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire la
transparence y compris de l'expertise
l'élévation continue des normes et la
reconnaissance du facteur humain nous
examinons un projet qui vise à accélérer
les procédures très bien nous faisons
partie de ceux qui sont plutôt enclins à
aller en ce sens nous disons depuis la
première minute de discussion en
commission que le risque de ce texte
c'est d'envoyer un contre signal sur la
question de la sécurité et de la Sûreté
Nucléaire et deux bonnes foi et en étant
enclin à regarder la question nucléaire
avec beaucoup de force nous considérons
que c'est un signal catastrophique et
nous souhaitons que vous oubliez cette
réforme de fusion je vous remercie vous
les procéder ici un démantèlement en
règle de l'Institut de radioprotection
sur la sûreté nucléaire ce n'est pas
nous qu'ils disons ce sont les
représentants des salariés de l'URSS
vous voulez d'abord fusionner les
fonctions de recherche et d'expertise
dans une autorité administrative la SN
qui procède aux sanctions aux
autorisations notamment vis-à-vis des
exploitants ça peut paraître technique
mais c'est extrêmement grave et moi qui
était chercheuse dans un organisme
public je peux vous dire à quel point et
par expérience une telle fusion va
déstabiliser pendant des années des
équipes de recherche qui sont
extrêmement pointues extrêmement
professionnels et dont nous voulons
saluer ici aussi le travail quelle
garantie avons-nous de la séparation
claire et effective d'un côté de la
recherche et de l'expertise et de
l'autre de la décision et je fais partie
de ceux qui pensent comme élange sans
précaution de ces trois fonctions ne
servira pas utilement la Sûreté
Nucléaire la deuxième question quelle va
être le devenir des missions de l'URSS
en particulier celle qui était portée
par sa fonction commerciale la fonction
commerciale de l'EPIC que vont devenir
le suivi du radon que va devenir la
surveillance de l'environnement que va
devenir le suivi de la radioprotection
en milieu médical que va redevenir la
sécurisation et la excusez-moi la
scénarisation et la gestion des
exercices de gestion de crise que va
devenir l'étude de la perception du
risque par les Français la troisième
question c'est celle de la transparence
sur les sujets de la sûreté de la
radioprotection et des rayonnements
ionisants l'IRSN a su construire la
confiance des Français il ne faudrait
pas la perdre aujourd'hui ce serait
dangereux mais vraiment dangereux sur le
plan institutionnel et pour le nucléaire
et ça sécurité et son assentiment par
les Français que de faire une telle
fusion ou un tel rapprochement en
l'absence de toute étude d'impact ce
serait une première elle serait
dangereuse nous estimons à l'échelle de
notre groupe qu'il s'agit là d'une
proposition de votre part qui est
abrupte et incompréhensible c'est une
question qui évidemment
participe à l'équilibre subtil mais
décisif entre expertise indépendante et
décision opérationnelle en matière de
sécurité de nos installations nucléaires
c'est un très mauvais signal nous vous
le répétons pour les professionnels
hautement qualifiés qui travaillent sur
la sûreté de nos installations et pour
le commun des Français en circonstances
donc nous voterons contre cet article 11
bis si le but c'est effectivement de
pouvoir fluidifier les procédures de
pouvoir également renforcer les équipes
pour des avis pour les projets qui vont
arriver en nombre dans l'Asie à venir je
pense que on peut toutes et tous
comprendre que c'est aussi un gage
d'efficacité derrière c'est certain
qu'il faut pas que nous puissions perdre
à la fois en sûreté à la fois également
en sécurité il y a à la fois
l'indépendance en tant que
Parlement qu'est-ce qu'on nous demande
de voter exactement
on nous demande de voter sans aucune
étude d'impact une mesure qui peut avoir
des conséquences sur la sûreté nucléaire
de notre pays on nous demande de voter à
l'inverse des conclusions de tous les
travaux parlementaires qui ont été faits
depuis 10 ans
lopex dit que c'est très bien comme ça
nous avons fait une commission d'enquête
parlementaire sur la sûreté nucléaire
dont j'étais rapporteur Paul Christophe
était président ça vous étonne pas quand
même que le président et la rapporteur
d'une commission d'enquête sur la sûreté
nucléaire qui sont membres de la
majorité et qui sont plutôt considérés
comme des gens modérés vous disent que
c'est une folie de nous balancer ça
comme ça à l'inverse de tous les travaux
que nous avons fait quel est le respect
du travail du Parlement dans ça enfin je
suis choqué de ça
je suis choquée le seul argument le seul
argument qu'on nous oppose c'est dans
d'autres pays on fait comme ça on a une
sûreté nucléaire française qui est
adaptée à notre système à nous et donc
le changer pourquoi pas mais on y
travaille on regarde on se réunit et
après on décide pas l'inverse je
voudrais convaincre le maximum de vous
tous quel que soit le banc sur lequel
vous situez qu'il faut s'opposer à se
démantèlement de l'IRSN chacun reconnaît
le niveau d'expertise de l'IRSN
nationalement et internationalement
reconnu d'ailleurs par la Cour des
comptes en 2021 qui dit qu'il remplit
ses missions et à trouver un équilibre
de fonctionnement chacun reconnaît ou au
moins consommons maintenant la nécessité
de séparer le processus d'expertise de
celui des décisions d'ailleurs la preuve
le gouvernement se dit prêt à
reconnaître un amendement qui garantit
dans le règlement de la SN c'est cette
séparation alors dans ce cas là pourquoi
pourquoi casser quelque chose qui
fonctionne depuis 30 ans la Sûreté
Nucléaire l'organisation de la sûreté
nucléaire a évolué on n'a pas eu un
modèle décidé au début du parc
historique ce qu'on aurait maintenu
jusqu'à aujourd'hui et c'est des
évolutions qui étaient légitimes parce
qu'on est dans une démarche de se
re-cestionner en permanence et pourquoi
est-ce qu'on le fait aujourd'hui on le
fait parce qu'au fond on est à une
croisée des chemins la filière nucléaire
était une croisée des chemins d'un côté
la prolongation du parc existant qui va
demander des investissements des études
extrêmement importantes et de l'autre le
renouvellement du parc historique avec
la construction c'est ce que l'on
souhaite de six plus 8 EPR 2 et donc ça
ça justifie et après chacun vote en son
âme est conscience mais ça justifie
qu'on ait le droit de se poser la
question de l'organisation de la sûreté
de l'organisation de l'exploitation en
France et c'est ce qu'on est en train de
faire ici il y a un réel questionnement
sur le fait que cet organisation n'est
pas la meilleure c'est ce que nous
disent les autorités intern ationales
c'est ce que nous disent l'observation
du benchmark international et c'est ce
que nous dit la Cour des comptes ça fait
beaucoup finalement d'experts qui sont
assez sachant sur le sujet nous ne
sommes pas opposés par principe à la
mutualisation de différentes agences à
l'heure des déficits abyssaux d'ailleurs
que connaît actuellement la France
mais comme le sujet n'est clairement pas
abouti et on le voit bien dans cette
hémicycle le groupe rassemblement
national s'absiendra sur cette fusion
c'est ce que nous avions fait c'est ce
que nous avions fait d'ailleurs en
commission je vous remercie résultat
du 7
l'Assemblée nationale n'a pas adopté
[Applaudissements]
les amendements de suppression sont
rejetés à deux voies près la fusion
semble donc actée mais l'affaire n'en
reste pas là avec un amendement de
réécriture du député IOT Benjamin sainte
huile qui relance le débat
on a acté le refus des amendements de
suppression et donc il s'agit là
d'amendement de réécriture qui vise à
conforter l'organisation dual de manière
à ce que nous ne revenions pas sur
l'organisation actuelle et je le dis
avec un brin d'humour il y a moins de
tension et moins de monde dans
l'hémicycle le collègue millième qui a
sans doute convaincu quelques-uns de
voter la suppression des amendements
nous a dit que le Parlement allait
reprendre la main je veux simplement
dire en respectant les uns et les autres
que la fusion si je la comparais de
manière un peu triviale c'est un mariage
nous sommes opposés à ce mariage et que
Monsieur miel nous propose d'être témoin
ce que nous refusons allègrement en la
matière je vais mettre
[Musique]
succession et gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
je vais compter mes chers collègues pour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la maman est adoptée
autre mesure phare l'alourdissement des
peines prévues en cas d'intrusion dans
une centrale nucléaire le rassemblement
national pousse pour alourdir les
sanctions les écologistes eux
s'inquiètent pour les actions menées par
des militants
[Musique]
article 13
Monsieur Emmanuel bléri merci
chers collègues cet article augmente les
peines prévues par le code de la défense
contre divers fait attentats la sécurité
d'installation nucléaire il s'agit d'une
évolution de bon sens contenue des
menaces pesant sur ces installations
éminemment stratégiques menace
intérieure d'abord de la part de
certains militants dont les dogmes
pseudo-scientifiques prévalent dans leur
esprit sur la véritable science menace
extérieure ensuite comme la rappel à nos
collègues Emeric Caron derrière le
nucléaire civil c'est aussi nucléaire
militaire qui est visé la tentation est
grande pour les mouvances terroristes et
les puissances étrangères de saper un
des derniers socle notre puissance
jusqu'à maintenant une se donnait pas
cette peine les gouvernements français
s'en charger maintenant qu'il s'agit de
relancer le nucléaire après cette longue
période d'abandon il convient d'agir
dans le sens du temps quand ces menaces
dont les méthodes et les modes d'action
se diversifient à mesure qui évoluent la
société la technologie ce texte demeure
insuffisant en l'état sur ce point et se
contente d'augmenter le quantum et la
nature des peines existantes pour les
faits incriminés mais ne prend pas en
compte par exemple l'usage de drone
lesquels sont de plus en plus
performants et nombreux ou éventualité
d'une personne d'une participation d'un
élu de la République à des faits
d'intrusion ce qui gouverne en manquait
encore une fois de plus l'occasion de
prévoir le traitement de ce type de
délit nous amendements suppléons ce
manque pour le reste le groupe
rassemblement national votera pour cet
article merci les propos qui viennent
d'être tenus par le rassemblement
national sont extrêmement graves parce
qu'il tend à mélanger deux choses des
militants ou représentants
d'associations
environnementales et des terroristes qui
voudraient avoir et qui ont visiblement
pas les mêmes fins et qui pourraient
poser des problèmes de sécurité grave je
pense que le triplement des peines ne
dissuadera pas les terroristes d'une
part par contre les actions des
militants écologistes qui ont été menées
sur certaines centrales ont permis aussi
d'AM les dispositifs de sécurité
aujourd'hui on est sur un abandon
totalement bâillon je rappelle que les
associations écologistes travaillent
pour l'intérêt général et ils ne sont
pas basés leurs actions ne sont pas
basées sur une pseudo science mais sur
une science bien étayée dont le
rassemblement national ferait bien d'en
faire lecture plutôt que de s'appuyer
sur des fantasmes idéologiques et en
tout cas c'est extrême enfin les propos
sont choquants pour nous la sécurité des
installations nucléaires est un sujet
majeur et nous pensons qu'il y a besoin
d'une réelle politique qui assure cette
sécurité qui agit sur la prévention et
la gestion des risques et nous pensons
aujourd'hui que de nombreux associations
écologistes sont utiles à ça à faire
pression pour que le gouvernement soit
au rendez-vous et bien de cette
politique qui qui agit sur sur
l'assurance sur la sécurité sur sur la
prévention des risques et les
dispositions prise ici par le Sénat sont
complètement
disproportionnées elles sont dans la
droite ligne des de l'inflation pénale
assez habituelle au Sénat mais elles
sont aussi je le crois dangereuses à la
fois pour les installations nucléaires
mais aussi parce que elles œuvrent à une
criminalisation de l'action écologiste
elles alimentent aussi une négation des
risques et c'est en ça que c'est
extrêmement dangereux et c'est pour ça
que nous voulons supprimer et bien cet
article nous proposons la suppression de
cet article parce que évidemment tout le
monde l'a bien compris il s'agit ici de
criminaliser encore plus les militants
notamment écologistes pacifistes qui
sont lanceurs d'alerte en termes de
sécurité nucléaire là on a affaire à une
surenchère pénale qui à la fois
dangereuse et inutile parce que juste
pour rappeler quand même les peines et
amandes qui existent sont déjà lourdes
et en l'occurrence elles sont
supérieures aux sanctions pour les
exploitants qui violent les règles
d'environnement et de sûreté par exemple
ça par exemple c'est pas grave 1500
euros seulement pour un rejet de
substance radioactive dans des nappes
phréatiques je vous laisse méditer
là-dessus les lanceurs d'alerte qui sont
introduisent dans les centrales n'ont
pas d'intention malveillante ils n'y
vont pas pour détruire quoi que ce soit
mais non ils vise justement à montrer
qu'il y a une faille dans la sécurité et
à permettre ainsi qu'on soit le plus sûr
enfin qu'on a qu'on assure la sécurité
de la population
voilà écoutez il faut quand même être
réaliste un accident sur une par exemple
un acte malveillant réellement
malveillant sur une centrale nucléaire
il suffit d'un accident grave et c'est
vraiment l'hiver nucléaire pour le coup
on n'est pas là pour plaisanter ça ne
justifie absolument pas cette
criminalisation merci madame la députée
madame la rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente déjà rappelé
que cet article a été retravaillé a été
retravaillée en commission parce que
effectivement le Sénat avait introduit
une hausse de peine qui pesait des vrais
difficultés typiquement certains délits
devenaient des crimes bon on sortait un
peu du chant du raisonnable donc on a
retravaillé ces hausses de peine sur
les peines d'emprisonnement et sur les
amandes et moi je suis très opposé à la
suppression de cet article parce que je
ne crois absolument pas que l'intrusion
sur des centrales sur des CNPE sur des
installations nucléaires de base soit
enfin permettent d'en améliorer la
sûreté ou d'en améliorer la sécurité je
vous le dis comme je vous le dis comme
je le pense certains utilisent le terme
des côtes terrorisme je pourrais le
reprendre je le ferai pas dans cette
hémicycle mais je pourrais le faire on
peut s'opposer au nucléaire et c'est
légitime de le faire il y a des
arguments qui sont parfaitement
intendables
mais pas mais pardon ça doit être fait
un cadre de la loi et c'est comme chaque
revendication donc aujourd'hui qu'il y
ait des peines et il y en avait bien
avant ce projet de loi en cas
d'intrusion sur un site c'est normal et
que le Sénat est souhaité augmenter ses
peines je le comprends on les a abaissés
parce que c'était allé trop loin mais je
me pose vraiment à la suppression des
articles alors moi j'étais pas parti
pour avoir une position de sagesse sur
cet article parce que le droit existant
il est pas mal écrit il est dur etc mais
quand j'entends les arguments de part et
d'autre j'avoue que je suis saisie
d'abord il y a aucune justification de
dire qu'un lanceur d'alerte dans un état
de droit pardon parce que nous sommes un
état de droit où vous avez une liberté
d'opinion une liberté de communication
une liberté d'exprimer ses opinions
médiatiquement sur les réseaux sociaux
partout vous soyez obligé de faire
d'aller
ne pas enfreindre la loi et d'aller
pénétrer sur un site nucléaire
deuxièmement cette espèce de romantisme
selon lesquelles lorsque vous rentrez
sur un site nucléaire vous repérer des
dysfonctionnements de la sûreté
nucléaire ou de la sécurité nucléaire on
est pardonnez-moi mais complètement à
côté de la plaque c'est pas sérieux ça
ne participe pas de la Sûreté Nucléaire
et je trouve ça dommage que sur un sujet
aussi sérieux on est d'un côté de la
caricature de l'autre côté de la
caricature donc moi j'invite à
finalement faire comme vous voulez
encore une fois le l'échelle de des
sanctions pénales il est fait pour être
proportionné il est fait aussi pour être
appliqué donc plus on les durcit moins
on les applique ça pose un problème un
versement si c'est pour donner le
sentiment que lorsqu'on est qu'on est un
rebelle au service de l'intérêt général
lorsqu'on va faire de l'escalade sur une
centrale nucléaire je suis désolé mais
c'est non voici le résultat du scrutin
votant sans neuf exprimé 108 majorité 55
pour 30 contre 78 l'Assemblée nationale
n'a pas adopté
suite de la discussion de l'article 13
avec un amendement défendu par le
rassemblement national pour autoriser la
vidéo surveillance avec des drones
c'est un moment vise à autoriser la
vidéo surveillance par drone des
établissements d'importance vitale tels
que les centrales nucléaires cela
permettra au service de l'État de
consulter plus rapidement les images
afin de déterminer si l'objet volant est
autorisé ou non à s'approcher d'une
centrale nucléaire et si ça n'est pas le
cas il faut autoriser la destruction de
l'appareil c'est une question de
sécurité nationale d'autant plus
nécessaire que la France subit en
permanence une menace terroriste réelle
je vous remercie merci madame la députée
madame la rapporteur des favorable à la
précédente madame la ministre satisfait
donc défavorable demande de retrait
je mets aux voix cet amendement qui a
reçu un double avis défavorable
commission et gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre l'amendement est rejeté
les articles
1133-13-13-12 à article
l133-13-13-14 du code de la défense
sanctionne les individus qui sans
autorisation de l'autorité compétente
pénètre des installations nucléaires
établissement ou installation abritant
des matières nucléaires si la région
pour laquelle afin d'assurer une
dissuasion plus importante face aux
risques peuvent comporter ce type
d'intrusion il convient de durcir les
sanctions encourues et c'est ce que
prévoit cet amendement de notre collègue
portier je donnerai un avis défavorable
en précisant que
suite au travail qui a déjà été initié
par le Sénat on a doublé l'ensemble des
peines d'emprisonnement et parfois
triplés les amandes pour les différents
délits qui concernent des intrusions
voire plus sur des centrales nucléaires
et on l'a fait en lien avec la division
des lois pour s'assurer que le principe
de proportionnalité des peines étaient
respectées et précisément pour que cet
article puisse être ensuite opérationnel
et promulguée donc ce sera un avis
défavorable pour les raisons que je
viens de vous expliquer et si possible
une demande de retrait je mets au voie
cet amendement qui a reçu un double avis
défavorable commission et gouvernement
qui est pour
qui est contre
l'amendement est rejeté nous allons
maintenant procéder au scrutin je vais
donc mettre au voile article 13 je vous
prie de bien vouloir regagner vos places
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin votant sans
exprimer 96 majorité 49 pour 75 contre
21 l'Assemblée nationale a adopté
le 21 mars 2023 l'Assemblée nationale se
prononce sur l'ensemble du texte en
première lecture
alors je vais mettre au voile le projet
de loi donc je vous demande de bien
vouloir regagner vos places
je vais attendre que notre dernier
oratrice puisse s'installer
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin votant 540
exprimés 532 majorité 267 pour 402
contre 130 l'Assemblée nationale a
adopté
après cette première lecture une
commission mixte paritaire composée de
députés et de sénateurs se réunit le 4
mai le 16 mai 2023 les députés votent le
texte adopter par la Commission
chers collègues ce texte aura tenu
toutes ces promesses tant sur le plan
technique que sur le plan programmatique
permettant d'avancer un peu plus vers
les objectifs fixés par le Président de
la République lors de son discours de
Belfort côté programmatique je pense
évidemment à la suppression du plafond
des 50% et à la suppression de la limite
de puissance installée décision prise
par François Hollande pour affaiblir la
filière sur la base de considération
idéologique au sujet de la réforme de la
SN et l'IRSN j'ai veillé conformément au
vote qui ont eu lieu dans cette
hémicycle à retirer du texte toute
mention directe ou indirecte à ce projet
de rapprochement cela vaut pour les
rapports qui mentionnaient des études à
ce sujet comme cela vaut pour
l'amendement de mon collègue Benjamin
sainte huile dont j'ai parfaitement
compris l'objectif mais qui venait
déséquilibré le système actuel puisqu'il
mettait sur un même plan la SN et l'IRSN
enfin l'article 13 à l'article 13 pardon
nous avons maintenu le renforcement des
peines de prison et des amendes en cas
d'intrusion sur un site nucléaire ainsi
que la possibilité donnée au juge
d'interdire l'ensemble des aides
publiques accordées notamment par l'État
ou par des collectivités à des
associations qui s'introduiraient
illégalement et dans certains cas sur
des sites nucléaires vous avez une
nouvelle fois la responsabilité de vous
prononcer sur un texte majeur pour bâtir
l'indépendance énergétique de notre pays
la responsabilité de vous prononcer sur
un texte qui contribuera au défi du
siècle libérer notre pays de sa
dépendance aux énergies fossiles alors
et je vous le dis avec conviction oui
accélérer le déploiement des énergies
renouvelables c'est être écologiste oui
relancer notre filière nucléaire c'est
être écologiste car comment se dit
écologiste en préférant les énergies
fossiles aux énergies décarbonées je
nous invite donc à poursuivre
collectivement le travail initier pour
bâtir la souveraineté énergétique de
notre pays je vous remercie et donc je
mets aux voix le projet de loi tel qu'il
est
issu de la commission mixte paritaire je
vous prie de bien vouloir regagner vos
places
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
donc votant 538 exprimés 499 majorité
250 pour
399 contre 100 l'Assemblée nationale a
adopté
[Applaudissements]
l'Assemblée nationale a définitivement
adopté le projet de loi sur la relance
du nucléaire la loi est publiée au
Journal officiel le 23 juin 2023 c'est
la fin de ce grand débat merci de nous
avoir suivi et à très bientôt sur LCP
[Musique]